hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play slender the
arrival the full game has finally been
released you can find it in the link in
the description below it's only ten
dollars and there's apparently a lot of
game to go through because it's pretty
big download it's been kinda hectic
getting to it but let's get started
right away
now like many of my games I actually
don't know a lot of the main story
[Music]
oh ho all right well it's bright and
sunshiny out so that's a good sign
well doesn't like too much I've got my
eye mounted camera ready to go I cannot
jump so let's go around it actually
looks really nice now
um this is showing my ignorance a bit
because I actually don't know what
engine this is made on some people said
it was made on the source engine some
people made it said it was made on the
unity engine but I'm not exactly a
hundred percent on that someone please
check me on that blue Isle Studios
proudly presents it looks phenomenal I
love all the grass textures I mean sorry
for the choppy resolution I record is
720p just to keep it easier on the
recording and uploading but you can
definitely appreciate it normally I've
anti-aliasing of engaged sorry can think
of word and unlike previous Slender
games there's actually a lot of story
that's going on I mean slender was it I
can t remember slender haunts under
haunt actually had a story to it mark
Hadley and garen marks a Mark Hadley is
he was a creative creator of the
original one I believe time and there
seemed to be a thomas nguyen that sounds
like a very familiar name i'm not sure
i'm actually looked at the extra support
of this it actually remembered that i
played the beta it's very smart about
that and it got i recorded time in there
so that'll probably help me get a little
extra content out of this when I beat
the main campaign which like I said
before I have no idea how long the main
campaign is gonna be see I don't know
what to expect but I'm very excited
because this is the original Slender
Creator this is a guy well you didn't
make the original Legend Legend actually
came from the something awesome
something awful forums a while ago about
six years ago I believe what the
original creepypasta was made but the
Slender game itself was released in July
or June of last year so it's a very
recent and this is a guy that made the
original Slender the a page so very very
excited to see what is in store that's
about all the gaming commentary I got so
let's get to this
and screaming cuz I'm an idiot Bing or
Romo I don't know really know what I am
but right now I seem to be walking in
the a light but I'm assuming that it's
gonna get dark soon and I'm going to be
trapped alone in the woods with
Slenderman that's usually how this goes
but I actually get to see how I get to
the point where I am oh is that a is
that a house
wait a minute no oh it's getting dark
it's getting dark quite quickly oh oh
I'm really excited to play this I hope
you guys all enjoy it for yourself
please support the developer he is work
that obviously worked with a lot of
people in his own production company to
bring um probably the best Slenderman
experience that you're gonna find around
because well it is his baby so he wants
it to be the best possible oh boy I get
to go into an abandoned house in the
middle of the night this is gonna be
phenomenal hello is anybody home Markab
are just walking in your front door
excuse me Oh
click hold and drag so it's like amnesia
style door opening here I like that I
wonder if he grabbed any other elements
of it because physical interaction is a
very ameesha style gaming thing what's
this flashlights batteries extra tapes
lighter kerosene locked the house lock
the house and then burn it down oh boy
item added to your scrapbook can be
viewed later from the menu okay I'll
check that later the phone line appears
to be dead that's a good sign hello Beth
Hayes honoring the life of Beth Hayes
obviously she has passed that got added
to my scrapbook as well let's see what
we got here like the atmosphere there's
tons of detail in this yes I have my own
little flashlight here Oh someone
obviously doesn't know know how to play
chess
yeah it's a good idea to start banging
on the keyboard or piano keyboard is not
a piano thank you I can't thank you
enough for coming out all this way to
help me it's been a pretty rough road
trying to sell this old place I wish I'd
turned to you sooner you have no idea
how happy I'll be once this is all
behind me love you always
Kate all right I'm getting a lot of
backstory here about this house appears
if someone's trying to sell it after a
tragedy happen Oh was this a married
couple or is this a mother and a
daughter I do not know can't tell at
this point but obviously some people
that used to live here don't live here
anymore
and frankly I can't blame them hey Kate
number one sorry something on my throat
it's been a while since we last spoke
hasn't it I hope you haven't forgotten
about me
I know writing a letter is a bit
old-fashioned but sometimes I just like
to sit down and write something out you
know so I can't remember what I was
doing at the time but all this stuff we
used to do when we were kids just came
rushing back to me all of a sudden the
other day remember when we'd sneak over
and over at night so we could both go
out on our own adventures ghost hunting
we'd call it we tried the flashlight
through the trees and jump at every
little insignificant noise our
imaginations were always working in an
overdrive I wish I could rewind back to
then seems like everything after that
time just hasn't been as good for both
of us how long is it blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah sorry ignore all
that I started rambling too much anyway
please let me hear from you soon I know
things have been less than normal for
you lately so I just wanted to check in
see our okay that's obviously no number
one I guess I'm collecting some notes in
the house oh my was that always there I
don't think so and I apologize if I have
something in my throat I don't know what
it is but something's been bugging me
hope I am NOT getting sick here but that
definitely was not there before let's go
upstairs see what's going on here I like
the decor of your house bad um hello
what's all this in key got a key good
for me I'm not insulting your
intelligence by reading what I've
already gotten you can obviously
oh well what's the point of that just
something a little extra Haddad of the
game to give it a little more
environment interactivity I'm guessing
or maybe it does serve some function I
do not know it is awfully dark and I do
not know what I am looking for obviously
I've been driving into this woods but I
don't know why I don't know who my
character is in relation to the people
in this house if there is any relation
at all okay that's good that's a good
sign that's a good thing these are
awfully nice bathrooms I mean these
bathrooms I've seen are bigger than my
room in my house so far so these people
shouldn't have a problem selling this
place other than that it's in the back
end didn't know where what I haven't got
in this room yet I'm not seeing anything
else note wise so so long as my camera
can stop freaking out I should be okay
hello anybody home obviously not or at
least I hope not
parsec productions as who made it
ooh what's that mmm interesting could be
another game Easter Egg that parts of
blue Isle Studios is working on her as
worked on her the past I don't know I
have not done much research into unlock
the door all from that key I picked up
earlier okay oh this is good so this is
where all the pages came from oh good I
finally found the source I do not like
this this is bad what is that I can't
tell I thought I might have seen swindie
in there oh goody what did I just pick
up a note oh lordy can you see it
nice scream I'm gonna I'm gonna go that
outside I'm gonna go outside because I
am compelled to and I'm an idiot so here
we go outside yeah I've always said in
all the other horror games that I've
played the atmosphere is paramount and
it's just coming all together in this
game and I love it
it's part of the subtle music playing in
the background and the small clues
building up to something I mean that's
what you absolutely need in these types
of games the door appears to be locked
well goody I guess I'll just have to go
around gah we have I been back here I
don't think I have hello another
bathroom Jesus how many bathrooms does
this house need how many people are
going to the bathroom here thanks for
calling last night it probably sounds
dumb but it was good to hear your voice
again good to hear that Lauren's been
doing really well too but yeah about
what we all said I'm not sure what to
think of it yet what are the odds of two
people having the exact same
hallucination could it really be just a
coincidence I have to go to my doctor to
gave her some today for some routine
stuff so I'm gonna try and casually
bring this up and see what he says about
it
Olay you know how it goes that's from
came on time it's just CR I'm not
getting it
[Music]
quiet down there's a Slenderman out
there don't you know that we're all
about to die
everyone here is about to die over the
garage I saw this door was open before
but I didn't go in it right away it's
not quite dark yet it definitely slowed
down on the pace all right let's go out
the back way because that's where the
scream was heard of and I'm assuming
that's where Slenderman is since check
the um play house first again I'm very
sad that I got something in my throat
but I guess that just adds to the raspy
a deep bass of my voice oh hello I'm
beginning all the nodes so this is good
hey Kay both my computer and phone have
been acting weird again lately so I
figured I'd do the old-fashioned way
glad we could meet up and dark things
through I agree what the doctor said -
there's an explanation for this stuff
the shared traumatic event sounds the
most logical to me that night out there
in the woods is probably what caused it
I had almost completely block that out
block that out but now it's kind of
coming back to me but like I said before
it's still really foggy I think the best
course of action right now to ignore yes
you should call Lawrence up that hello
oh look a slide we came and unlocked yes
I am the greatest God I'm great but you
all didn't get that one oh that was fun
let's go die in the woods oh loading
screen so I am a female I'm a female
character and this looks familiar
ah this is where I started in the demo
version where you could do an eight-page
uh style hunt for the notes it's Slendy
leaves or it may not be Slendy now that
leaves him I thought it was Slendy snows
before but this kind of throws a wrench
in that with the whole room being
serenaded in a whole bunch of Slendy
babes
alright so am i hunting for pages again
I've already gotten three so I don't
know how many more I will need hello Oh
joyous day Callooh Callay Oh frabjous
day
Callooh Callay
I get to play the eight pages again yes
my favorite I assume that this would be
a part of it but I'm assuming that if I
managed to get all eight pages I can go
out and have fun in my own there another
one here yes there is okay I think I
remember all the locations even though
they are randomized there's a general
pattern of the layout of the land follow
the outside circuit make sure you hit
all the outside locations before going
in blender you're here a little early I
am no longer need your services anymore
please go away and die no I don't even
see them oh there he is
whoo did he get taller goody goody
gumdrops okay I think this is the
outside perimeter still you still back
there buddy yep yep okay so I'll hit
this and then I'll try to get n-words
you stay back you stayed back buddy I
know you just want a little hug okay got
four of eight already doing pretty good
my practice with the demos aided me
significantly and I think uh here's the
rocks so actually let me make sure I
knew there was another path over here so
let me make sure that I absolutely get
all the outskirts on one side because I
do not want to be lost in the woods
again like I have before I mean when I
was playing for the news team I wasn't
able to complete it like I was the first
time but that's probably because I
didn't plan my route route route route
whatever okay the music's getting a
little heavy well let's just stay calm
everybody stay calm out there I have
this under control me markiplier is
currently to prowl you're not prepared
right now where I need that page you
[ __ ]
I need that pager [ __ ] I need it I
moaning I'm gonna swing around God right
now go I'll come back for it later
I'm not gonna risk getting caught by you
when I leave these pages I need to get
this to progressed in the story I don't
even know what the saving mechanic is in
this game so there may be one there
maybe not you go away you [ __ ] where
are you
well there you are you right behind me
Oh nike's he is actually following me
that is not good but then again I do
have five pages so he's bribed little
ticked off that I'm getting this so
quickly and don't be mistaken I do not
believe that if I get these eight pages
it to see end of the game that is not of
the state of play here aha little shack
up here oh the sign is up here why is
the sign up here all right I just got to
find one more location probably inside
the building I'm a circle around try to
get the lie or the water tower
I got a circle back at the water tower
and then I'll have only one location to
go and I'm out of a sprint you step back
you [ __ ] I am I'm the greatest set of
player to ever play slender so you back
off you [ __ ] don't you know who I
already said that okay stop it I need to
win I need to win you stop it
you stop it you son of a [ __ ] I have
the water tower in my excites I got it
you're not gonna keep me from my
objective breath
I seem to be I must have done my aromas
Isaac because I can run quite a bit just
got to get this and get out of here god
you're such an a-hole good seven of
eight he's getting much closer now did I
get the one on the car yeah I got the
bolt car in the truck so it should just
be the one in the building and I should
just make a straight shot from here to
there
I just gotta gets one Martin I'm good
okay
slender brows do pro to be stopped by
Slendy and I mention uh playing this at
exactly midnight and it's really good
okay I'm hoping I do okay I seem to not
have a limit to my sprint which is
awfully nice with me trying to get away
from Slendy that majors because I'm
playing unnormal you're not hard just
normal difficulty here try to get away
from Slendy who is a little [ __ ] ah
here's the building so it's got to be in
here somewhere but I've been lost in
here before so this may be the death of
me or I may actually make it out alive
oh please be an easy spot please be in
one of these rooms I do not want to be
caught fudge I do not want to be caught
with my pants down in front of Slendy
man oh come on being here oh come on
I got it give me a time 800 who's the
winner I'm running I'm not doing it what
am i doing I'm I'm actually controlling
rabbi hello I passed out in the woods
Sunderman did not eat me alive hello hi
oh good its day
that's a nice scenery okay so here's to
hope and then it's saved in some way
when we see um charcoal explore the area
I'm hoping that it's saved in some way
if not I will have to get back here but
I think that is a good stopping point
for now I will continue this adventure
because I didn't think that the game
would end right then and there because
with the eight pages I've got eight
pages like record time I did great on
that one it's all my practice from the
beta so anyway thank you guys so much
wrong this is pretty much everything
that I have imagined it to be if you
haven't already if this haven't
convinced you if you want to stop
watching here and buy the game for
yourself and finish the game before you
continue I will be doing a series out of
this
Ahnold there will be multiple parts so
please please go support the indie
developers this game is great so much
work has been placed into it and the
atmosphere is just fantastic I mean this
is the original Flener maker it's it's
just enormous ly great huge world just
beautiful environments I love I love
every everything about it I have
literally no criticisms about the game
so far but we will see at the end of the
game for now I am all out of time so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos if I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]